let's just do it here we go the purge
election year so the purge election year
is the third purge movie hopefully the
concluding chapter of the purge trilogy
in this movie a senator played by
Elizabeth Mitchell's running for
president her first order of business is
to close the purge just end it all and
of course they who run the country are
like she's a problem yeah we must use
the purge to eliminate her so that's
what happens Frank Grillo plays the head
of her security so he's trying to just
save her ass pretty much along with
slight characters horrid dialogue a
shitty script just a rabble [ __ ]
that is the purge election year right
what worked in this movie first of all
Elizabeth Mitchell and Frank Grillo they
carry this movie because they're the
only real viable characters and viable
performances in the entire thing Micheal
T Williams in Bubba from Forrest Gump he
was actually good also he had a couple
of good lines in the movie some shitty
lines in the movie too but to be fair to
him everybody in this movie has shitty
lines is all about how they deliver the
[ __ ] example is one thing we're like
it's like there's purge coverage for
your store the government pulls his
purge coverage and he hangs up the phone
he's like I'm just gonna have to defend
this shop myself I was like oh oh oh so
this is what the dialogue is gonna be
like eighties cartoon all right now
we're in for it and that would work if
the movie didn't try to have relevant
social commentary on political and
social issues I'm not against a movie
doing that at certain movies should do
that but do you really think this
nonsense is the canvas for that and the
acting I'm just gonna this is my
favorite I was looking forward to
talking about the shitty acting in this
movie the two main characters aside it's
all the acting a porn not remotely as
enjoyable as porn there's this bunker on
the movie always has to look up like
this because that's how crazy people who
keep a book I'm gonna kill you [ __ ] I
want my candy bar what the [ __ ] in the
bad guy in this movie has these tattoos
that are straight-up like the best
sharpie job I guess they could do and
his crew wearing these patches like
Lou's swastika patch and a confederate
flag patch is basically they're like we
need to establish that these guys are
bad news
did I stress enough that the acting
dialog is just horrendous sicknesses
quite bad people were laughing in the
movie and scenes they shouldn't have
been laughing people were laughing as if
this was a comedy and then the ending of
course gets so over the top the movie
overreaches even more and the acting
gets completely worse these new players
come in you're like maybe they're not as
that no they're bad they're just as bad
no they're worse acting gets worse the
closer to the end of the movie you get
except for miss I want my candy bar stay
in the pocket man the purge anarchy was
fine for what you were going for for the
purge you want a purge I'll give you a
purge the purge election year is [ __ ]
there's your purge right there
admittedly the movie does move into the
bracket of so bad it's good territory
like Batman and Robin and that if you
want a good life you can still wash it
with friends and just pick this movie
apart like Mystery Science Theater and
[ __ ] you'll have a good time with it
possibly but that doesn't change the
fact that this movie and Batman and
Robin are both dog [ __ ] so is your dime
man you do what you want to do I'm just
letting you know what you're in for all
right so the purge election year have
you seen it what did you think about it
and what's the movie with the worst
acting ever for you whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more